à l'école j'étais un élève mayall
questionnement avait permis à certains
moments allez on trouve tous donc 5 août
autrefois il est comme mon placard
virginie pouteau à trois vies
professionnelles institutrice à mi temps
animatrice d'ateliers d'écriture et
écrivain public depuis trois ans trois
univers liés par une passion unique et
dévorante l'amour des mots il faut
écrire chaque jour chaque journée on est
amené à écrire et qui a le plaisir ça
nous porte de toute façon les chrétiens
moi je trouve que les mots l'écrit c'est
un compagnon de chaque jour et c'est
finalement ce n'est pareil pour beaucoup
de personnes mais ils n'ont pas
conscience
c'est tout pour moi alors elle tient la
main de ceux qui la sollicitent pour une
lettre administrative un récit
autobiographique où une remise à niveau
en couchant sur le papier des mots qui
traduisent toujours des émotions
c'est en discutant que les crises se
fait et c'est ça qui est enfin c'est ça
qui est très agréable dans le métier
d'écrivain public c'est que j'ai
rencontré moi alors je peux très bien
travaillé avec des adolescents des
adultes et jeunes adultes qui ont 20 à
25 ans et j'ai rencontré aussi des
personnes qui sont en difficulté sociale
et c'est hyper intéressant tôt tous les
échanges qui peuvent se faire à ce
moment-là ça c'est un des grands
plaisirs de l'écrivain je suis impatient
de savoir comment elle s'appelle déjà
cole en tulle et un petit pois roses
pâles ça c'est que ce soit à qui il
arrive clad aventure le plaisir d'écrire
virginie le partage avec enthousiasme
dans son village
deux après midi par mois dès ce soir
des quotidiens depuis septembre une
dizaine d'enfants écoliers ou collégiens
consacre trois heures par séance à
l'écriture et à la lecture
certains étaient venus à recul en tout
ce sont aujourd'hui de compte déclare
des histoires partout que les bains
c'est bien les histoires et on peut les
lire après et on peut exprimer nos
sentiments c'est pour les rêves pour
m'aider à faire aux moments parce que je
veux être vraiment écrivant ce matin
juste a écrit rien
faire imaginer ton imagination et ça
marche
le résultat en cinq mois seulement est
bluffant ils mangent 40 des licornes
crapules kurde du journal je m'appelle
collange les à petits pois roses pâles
gt3 son frère et servent un succès pour
la virginie animatrice à faire pâlir la
virginie enseignante
j'essaie de trouver ce moment là en
classe mais c'est vrai que ce sont des
moments rares parce qu'il ya
l'institution à ce que ya le programme
parce qu'il faut passer à l'action
suivante
et puis même eux ils sont pas notés
c'est juste pour le plaisir se lave avec
de la mousse à la recette du mirage le
bonheur de lire et d'écrire existe
encore au 21ème siècle
fait une belle jambe
[Musique]